[music]
we have achieved that we significantly improve the
living and social conditions of
2,000,000 drivers
significantly improve
there is an absolute ban on sleeping
in the entire european
union harmonizing and without exception
the driver has the right every three
or four weeks at the latest
coming home
we didn't
plan for the kapo to further liberalize
koling from five days onwards
we have an application of the posting
regulations that means equal pay
for the same work in the same place from
the first day that also applies to the
capital injections received reports on it
is important  if there is something
extreme an important 2006 the red card
are 2007 team is rank that received
pragmatic way to remove from european
road safety it is better priority
a slider of the
ministers division investment in the future